blake shelton has won the voice more
than any other coach and now we're gonna
find out if he has to touch to turn in
one winner into the show's very first
music superstar yeah blake announced
today that when he hits the road next
month he's taking his latest champion
along for the ride
this guy deserves the best star and
there's no excuses anymore this is the
guy that I think can break the mold and
become a star out of this show Blake
Shelton not just talking to talk today
he took action the country star
announced he's taking his voice champion
Sundance Head with him on tour
Blake told et this morning quote there's
a tremendous number of talented people
that come on the boys and the talent and
connected with viewers is real and
tangible eg o-line senior music editor
sobytia' lacy says there's another issue
at play the boys might be the most
successful singing competition out there
but it really hasn't produced a
superstar like Kelly Clarkson Carrie
Underwood Jennifer Hudson even Adam
Lambert here's the thing I've been
covering the voice for a few years now
and the one thing that Blake always
tells me is that he genuinely feels
really guilty when his contestants don't
make it to superstardom you can't help
but become friends with some of these
people and if you have a string or two
you can pull home I mean why wouldn't
you do that you know Blake's definitely
gonna give thirty seven-year-old
Sundance a boost here but there is
another angle to all of this and that is
the record deal that the contestants get
after the show
Blake's spoken out about it so has Adam
Levine actually and the consensus seems
to be that the coaches believe the
record label doesn't really have a
clear-cut
plan
this morning I spoke to Sundance by
phone about the exciting news what are
some of the secrets of making it in
country music the Blake has shared with
you well you just gotta be really
persistent and try to follow your dream
as hard as possible it's never gonna be
easy what kind of things are you gonna
be looking for specifically when you're
out there with Leigh contour watching
him perform every night I just I really
need to pay attention to see how he's
gonna work the crowd and really see what
kind of energy that he brings to his
live performances I really have a lot of
room to grow and I'm really excited to
just watch these professionals and find
what they're doing the best and try to
apply that to everything that I do
[Music]